alors il ya plein de questions gigogne
par votre affaire je vais essayer
données de quelques règles avec
lesquelles
personnellement je bats ma réponse la
première c'est que tout sauf la guerre
donc à chaque fois que je pense qu'il
d'évolution subi vous emmène de manière
trop brutale vers le chaos judas ya un
risque majeur hors guerres et je
n'interprète pas autrement que par la
contrainte économique elle même liée à
la contrainte énergétique la montée du
populisme que l'on voit partout en
europe et dont le dernier exemple viable
nous est donné je crois que vous avez
quelques représentants s'étaient
spéciaux en lâcher d'eau et la dernière
le dernier exemple a été donné en italie
il ya bien longtemps
c'est très homogène sur l'or et soit dit
en passant le tea party aux états unis
ont poussé voilà c'est quelque chose qui
est pas propre à mon sentiment c'est
qu'il ya un risque désagrégation sociale
fort à suivre la ligue 2 caen sans rien
faire
après quand je quand je vous dit tout à
l'heure les profs ça n'existe pas mon
critère est toujours le même
comme l'énergie sans risque n'existe pas
la seule question est toujours la même
c'est est-ce qu'une énergie donné dans
le contexte dans lequel on utilise évite
plus de risques qu'avant tout c'est ma
grille de lecture
donc si ça il y plus de risques que ça
d'encre et j'achète si c'est jamais sans
risque la bible ne risque pas fini par
en mourir comme dj click mais on ne sait
jamais sans risque la question encore
une fois c est ce que j'ai vite eu plus
de réussite que je m'en fais alors le
nucléaire peu moins différent c'est que
des mauries il est dit plus de risques
qu'il enchaîne donc rester il en a vécu
ce qu'il faut faire avec ça c'est pour
la règle ministre avec le nucléaire
d'une manière générale je suis partisan
de gérer empreint de sérieux et méthode
sérieuse alors ça veut dire quoi j'avais
enfin sérieux et méthode sérieuse ça
veut dire qu'à chaque fois avec des
coups droits afin pour les particuliers
exemple comment faire fonctionner et
l'ulb dans un contexte dans lequel j'ai
pas plus d'argent j'ai moins d'énergie
c'est peu probable que la solution chez
vous ça serait de mettre les panneaux
solaires sur le toit a dit m
les trois c'est mieux l'isoler des
bâtiments c'est encore mieux de faire en
sorte le temps en temps les étudiants ce
déplacement pour venir ici et c'est la
solution au problème
elle passe par des méthodes et une qu'en
dire elle passe par un non-sens de
méthode
donc là tout à fait les hommes elle ne
passe jamais par le bois de
passe-partout et y acheter la boxe il
était là et bien maintenant c'est pas m
j'étais bien qu'il ya un certain nombre
de constructeurs de boîte en question
qu'ils nous disent c'est comme ça que ça
marche toujours est donc ça va vraiment
être ou droit de chaque pays de chaque
situation de chaque question posée il ya
déjà eu des trucs qu'on peut faire et
d'éviter d'en rajouter dans les
conneries chedjou dans un projet en ce
moment d'aéroport l'emprise de brandon
alors il faut savoir aussi soit dit en
passant que les gens qui prennent
l'avion ces niches des riches des fils
de riches d'étudiants instrument encore
pas très riche que souvent c'est des
fils de wade donc les gens qui prennent
l'avion du ch pour moi je trouve assez
farce qu'un premier ministre socialistes
fassent une infrastructure pour riches
de rigoler mais donc des gens peut
commencer par arrêter les conneries et
ensuite ça c'est un avis personnel et
ensuite il ya une manière de prendre le
problème qu'on soit dans une usine avant
dans un pays dans une région
collectivités dans une université chez
nous toutes ces tares vous aurez
toujours un cocktail de mesures
techniques de mesures économiques parce
que quand vous avez un bout de marché
dans la manière dont fonctionne
l'économie
vous aurez besoin de simon prix qui sont
faits pour ça que vous donner un exemple
vous pouvez très bien remettre en place
un impôt annuel sur la détention d'une
voiture qui soit très fortement 300 en
fonction de la consommation de la
voiture
si vous faites ça vous n'excluez pas de
la mobilité motorisée les gens ont
besoin d'ingrédients pour aller au
boulot il y aura un petit machin points
donc vous empêcher la voiture entre les
statuts conserver la voiture en génie
militaire vous l'acceptez chrétien est
grand parce que la voiture
pardon encore de cette expression du
diable chez les hommes c'est un encours
de québec et chez les femmes c'est
l'impression de la sécurité un départ
chez d4 quatre filles parce qu'elle
pense que comme ça dans votre sécurité
quand il ment les vols donc le donc ça
ça n'a rien à voir que ça c'est de
l'humain 100%
elle n'a strictement rien à voir avec
des considérations techniques car votre
voiture sur pièce sur roulettes
jibril se déplace donc le les objets
pour limiter fortement la consommation
d'énergie et faire de l'énergie
décarbonée xsara après tout ça qui va
faire pleurer
et pour finir sur le nucléaire parle on
a commencé est ce que vous êtes
je sais pas ce que des familles et
quelques sur sa bonne bouille capitale
quand le coût du capital et 8 pour sorte
le réacteur vedette fois qu'il est moins
en moins le compte de gens qui lui
disent non d'areva le p r ou crash
mégawattheure à 85 90 euros à 10 % taux
d'actualisation
est ce que vous savez après ça descend à
d'autres centres d'actualisation quart
d'heure le plus bas de ce que nous
trouvions 20 ans pour beaucoup de
centrales en service mais c'est ce que
je disais il faudra peur parce que fada
pas chez moi passent aussi parce qu il
faut vingt ans parce que c'est dangereux
en riant il faut maintenant parce que le
capital est pas de bon sens mais à 8 sur
les émissaires tribaux et c'est donc à
cause de tout ça vous voyez bien que là
on est dans un contexte dans lequel
s'est pas juste la technique le sujet
c'est tout un ensemble de trucs qu'on a
fait il se doit d'être lui dit oui
le modèle économique si je vous donne
les grandes lignes alors là je vais
maintenant yakafokon mais après dans les
grandes il faut absolument le des
financiarisé la financiarisation de
l'économie et d'un poison mortel le
sujet dont on parle parce que ça
rappelle aussi les horizons de temps on
va donc vous faites plus rien à 50 ans
l'économie financiarisée 50 ans n'existe
plus si on financière les haines et les
questions de nos gosses tard après la
sortie d' amateur donc fait plus rien la
deuxième règle et ce qu'il sait qu'il
faut faire un grand soir fiscal il faut
que j'ai aussi un petit patron - je peux
payer les impôts par montant payé 350 de
différent à 42 euros 50 par un pot donc
je pense que l'on n'a pas besoin d'un
grand soir fiscal avec un basculement
très fort de la fiscalité de ce qui nous
emmerde pas peur tout le temps donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut des taxes et
travaille très bien et il faut taxer les
énergies fossiles entre autres choses la
consommation de ressources l'espace
occupé il faut aller vers des impôts de
stock
si votre pays besson vellas casser la
gueule tout
sont prélevés sur une fraction du pib
allait avoir un petit sujet pour faire
tourner la puissance publique
donc il vaut mieux passer sur des impôts
de scop moins qu'auparavant ça revient
avec les véritables